wish they did like a video series of
like tops who reluctantly bought them
because their faces are so it's like
dragging a kid to church it's like that
kind of a Vibe you don't know how right
that is yes
oh my God and that's so funny I didn't
think about that yeah no we're we're
both very like verse you know so
sexually very compatible yes very
compatible but it's interesting then
that's like a huge privilege for
straight relationships is and you meet
someone that you really get along with
and you love and you Vibe with sexual
components already worked out right
right they have the whole women we have
the thing that fills a hole you guys
could meet your love your
both want to be filled
now what do you do you go to a Broadway
show yeah I mean you're like fine we'll
go to cats again